that's like the genie that plays a trick
on you do like you want to be Michael
Jackson and then I show up and [__]
Joe Jackson's beating my ass
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys and
today it's okay can we see you and today
we have men from what's the mortgage
oh man our question for you man
everybody know the movie Space Jam we
was talking about this prompt the other
day everybody know the movie Space Jam
yeah the good one I never I haven't
watched any of them I haven't watched
any of them I forgot I know Prince the
first one we don't have to reference
this let me let me ask you guys what
does Marvin the Martian do in Space Jam
I don't know I didn't watch it okay all
right all right so all right guys
there's a scene in there where they're
[__] the aliens right the the Tune
Squad or whatever what besides aliens
the [__] the aliens yes they're
[__] aliens all right and they want
to steal NBA basketball players power so
what they do is they got this Magic
basketball right they takes Magic
Basketball they hand it around once
people like Charles Barkley and Larry
Bird Mugsy bozie and stuff like that
they touch this basketball their [__]
Powers get sucked into it and then after
that these [__] aliens they're
[__] aliens right they take the
skills they put them into themselves
grow into these Titan basketball players
the mon stars and they go off like crazy
right yeah now if we had that same
basketball
who out there in the world would you
Space Jam steal their powers and why
oh
that's a good question Michael Jackson
yeah and which Powers did you steal oh
Jesus oh man this is going to patreon
well I already danced pretty good so I
don't need his dance skills but what
skills do you need music skills not as
not as communication with children
I mean I connect with kids pretty good
already so I don't need that skill okay
so you think you'd be as equally
Successful by having Michael Jackson's
music skills without actually being
Michael Jackson
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah if you didn't see that coming right
yeah that's good would you care if you
got his his uh Career Success or do you
just want his talents uh damn dude I'll
be sick because if I could if I had that
money remember when you went to that
store I love that store in Vegas by the
way it's uh it's at the Caesars Palace
but there's also another one at the
Venetian I believe but it's that [__]
goddy ass store where you walk around he
goes I want that oh yeah I want how much
is that it's like 70 000. put it on my
bill yeah I want to be able to do that
you only yeah you only get his skills
you don't get his money right with Space
Jam it's not like they [__] got
Charles Barkley's like entire life Floyd
Mayweather's boxing skills oh you never
get hit you got your money that's a good
one but you can't read but I can count
so you get there like non-powers I
didn't know that's how the basketball
worked but for the sake of this yes so
you you you want it just for the defense
not even to make money off it you
wouldn't be a pro boxer no I'd be a pro
boxer but like think about he's a boxer
didn't get hit yeah so a lot of boxers
that are good still got hit yeah and
that's why they're all [__] up in the
head and now he's just fighting
YouTubers he's just beating the [__] out
of YouTubers and making money you know
just raking it in that's a good that is
a good one pretty good that's a good one
[__] yeah why do I need a Space Jam
steel man I feel like I could Space Jam
a lot of people like what else who else
all right wait a minute all right all
right all right check this out all right
Arnold Schwarzenegger what skills
without having to work out
wait what you know how you okay but then
you would bankrupt California
to get to where he is right yeah I just
want to wake up one day I'm the I got a
movie I get to be the Terminator
I get to have you seen Space Jam he said
he hasn't no but like I'm just saying
because he's talking about skills I
think you're changing his life I wanted
life I want the skills to his life
all right are we changing the prompt of
the video
he's like I want to talk about my
favorite dessert actually
you gotta take their skills like their
talent all right but their talent gets
sucked into you but it's Talent is hard
work and then if you if I suck into it
then I don't even get to do the hard
work [__]
but you just took the skill of hard work
so you can use it now that's too much
work bro
he just wants to look like Arnold that's
pretty funny
what about you Ryan and me the man of
many talents yeah you already have I
know you already got this skills you're
like Thanos you just need one more Stone
um
because it wouldn't be Powers but like
you know there was I was looking up this
name because I wasn't sure who it was
but her name's Henrietta Lacks and in
1951 she died of like a camp like some
kind of cancer or something but they
preserved ourselves and they found out
her cells uh replicate immortally wait
what you know about that no no
but she died though yo yeah she died but
like her her cells live forever
there's she has she's the only person in
the world that ever had cells like that
so they continually do tests using her
cells they're called the the I want to
get this right Hala the Hala cell so the
Halo cell is henrietta's actual cells
that to this day
they just replicate forever that's like
the immortal jellyfish they don't die
but then not that I would
take her power but like I would want to
fight a person like that that has
something that has an immunity to like
cancer or something so you never die
well let's say well don't die of that at
least I want I want fauci's Power of of
persuasion
I can make anybody do anything man
I could lock down whole countries with
stupid reasons I could [__] backtrack
a million times and never get in trouble
and [__] win a Nobel Peace Prize dude
that'll be sick got pretty good
persuasion skills
I think he's like also even if they find
anything I think he's been uh what's
called um exonerated or yeah he can they
can't come after breathing yeah oh what
don't worry he's got the like the like
super protecting it if they even if they
catch it like I think a year five yearly
like he's like
he's got him he has like immunity yeah
for the longest time though I would say
Brian McKnight singing and keys and even
guitar skills because he's an insane
musician and then also Jamie Foxx Jamie
Foxx I would I would I would go with
James like his triple threatness is
crazy
and everything like that he's a man yeah
that's crazy Jamie Foxx is a good one
yeah have you guys heard him and uh
Kevin Hart doing a roast back and forth
oh dude it was so funny because uh on
Joe Rogan what he was talking to but he
was just saying how like
um like they were talking about Jamie
Foxx about him being one of the most
talented people alive and not only is he
a good though even comedy there's like
the different aspects of Comedy right
like everyone knows his sets are really
good his character work is pretty good
but roasting is a completely different
art form and then so I think Joe Rogan
mentioned oh you guys know how to watch
this thing where him and Kevin Hart were
uh going back and forth and I think one
of the lines Jamie said was like your
nostril's so big I can see her brain
like it was I was like oh I didn't even
know Jamie was like that style you know
but he's just so talented it's like
he'll pick up any art form and he's just
like bam he just kills me
it's so funny your nostrils so big I can
see your brain
watching Kevin Hart uh roast uh Meek
Mills dude that was funny just
he's pretty good
dang I don't know because then most of
the thing you're thinking about is
ability right but what other see that's
why I try and change it you guys didn't
let me change it to be something more
interesting
it's a dime I might go uh I don't know
if this is for some reason this is a
more practical approach in my head
because I don't even know who this
person is but I would just try and steal
the skill of like the number one like
first person shooter gamer in the world
or something like that yeah ninja like
the number one
yeah yeah Esports because yeah because
one it's like I feel like from like a uh
because I think in my mind I'm like do I
want like Rory mcilroy's golf skills
right now I don't want you know what I
mean but that might have a threshold
that will end at some point of my
physical peak whereas I'm like from a
gaming perspective if I was like the
number one at some type of gaming even
if they make new games more or less
they're gonna work in similar fashion so
you're thinking about success though
well because I would have to use the
skill for Success no because mine I uh I
don't even know if I would have it
reached the public you would have a
skill and you wouldn't want to share it
music so much
um that I wish that I wished I could
feel things the way they did because you
have to be Master to feel the way things
are trying to be like pie man I'm
[__] kill Bill hey I might feel the
same way gaming dude I might just enter
Zen you know what I'm saying like I'm
sure he cares about 7 000 more notes
that I can hear
you know what I mean so I'm like if I
could like even just experience that in
a closed room
[Laughter]
that's why Michael Jackson and you're
not yeah dude in a closed room you guys
hear that what the [__] is that okay
what about you Nick I just got mine
dunked on yeah Nick Nick just finally
wants a black belt they're just gonna be
you Space Jam could be space oh that'd
be tight that was obviously that's the
easy one but Nick wants to be hasbola
then you'd have to fight bro yeah I
would take [__] Warren Buffett's
Financial skills oh his ability to what
about Pelosi's Pelosi's Pelosi is better
than Warren Buffett you know what I take
Pelosi's tits I'm just kidding no I
would do uh like Warren Buffett's fine I
do Warren Buffett's like Finance
business Acumen that's what I would take
oh you think that's pretty good yeah or
Prince Andrew's ability to not get
extradited for his crimes that's pretty
that's a pretty sick skill damn that's a
tough that's really sick yeah I don't
know which one I want yeah dude he's in
the picture and he still didn't
if it's like business Acumen or
something like that like the way he he
thinks of the way like his skills that's
what I would say you know how you said
Habib is never gonna fight again yeah
that's a good way of getting him to
fight again if you just Space Jam and
then you go fight oh I would I would I
would you know I'll be like I'll
represent with you yeah um put me on
your team bruh draft me so then I gotta
fight people and I'm like oh man
but all of these come with the curse
though it's like you're Warren Buffett
but dude you look like Warren Buffett oh
that's the curse you know what I mean
and he's Frugal he's super Frugal with
that much cheap dude with that much
money it doesn't matter what you look
like though but I'll take his skill set
right yeah and then I'll apply it to my
life you know what I mean yeah but he's
so old he can't do Jiu Jitsu
yeah so I gotta take his body so you you
have to take the skill the good and the
bad back to taking the body yeah dude
well then Joe's [__] Michael Jackson
he's dead his nose changes and [__] like
nah when he was alive come on
which era of Michael would you take then
that means you can't be any of the
plastic part you could just be him for
real
Moonwalker Mike oh I'm not gonna be
black Mike I'm gonna be Peter Pan Mike
because that's that's artificial if
you're gonna be somebody you have to be
the Flesh and Bone don't you yeah that's
the yeah the Moonwalker mic from
Moonwalker he was already a little
light-skinned for that wouldn't he yeah
but that's still mine
and you think Michael yeah you you would
think what about if you were the that
the baby Michael
that's when he was being abused though
[__] I don't know man
that's like the genie that plays a trick
on you dude like you want to be Michael
Jackson and then I show up in [__]
Joe Jackson's beat my ass and [__] yeah
yeah that's that's your loophole dude
yeah every all of them because Genies do
[__] you up dude Michael Jackson there's
some Jafar [__] up there so if
Anthony Lee has to take the the skills
of the best like video game player yeah
you have to stream like 17 hours and I
forgot carpal tunnel and nerd neck yeah
and that was like oh yeah please but I
have to do it yo immediately your head
just sinks into your shoulders you
start smelling yeah you smell like
Cheeto and [__] virgin you know
[Laughter]
do you know that was like an actual like
wide uh complaint about the N64
championships that everyone smelled yeah
that the stench was so bad people people
didn't want to go to them
why you think Gamers think they don't
shop you guys ever heard of them bad
hygiene happens poop sock
the what
yeah when they're [__] gaming so hard
they don't want to leave so they [__]
[__] in their sock and [__] okay the
sock is a really small opening in order
to imagine you're dropping loads with
the buttholes did you just use a bag
imagine you just miss it yeah play it on
your controller that's gaming in another
way that's not good for you man that's
that's really bad yo don't look at me
like I'm actually [__] I can't believe
you man I cannot believe your answer now
we judge you what the [__] dude that'd
be funny I just if Michael Jackson's dad
just keeps beating
you wanted to be Michael he's like I
don't want to say anymore and you have
to live like the worst years
you can't go out and play you just got
your ass beating practice
I wanted the Neverland Ranch
if you pick Jamie Foxx you have no
disadvantages your life is chilling
unless I'm stuck in uh like a Ray
Charles
what the what the [__] [__] or you're
stuck being the cello player but you're
actually homeless
on the back of my head the whole time
yeah yeah damn it what a ripoff
Jamie Foxx is probably the best answer
out of all of us that's not badly yeah I
think so because he says he has so many
great skills he's never had a bad
Scandal really yeah that's what I was
gonna say that one bad movie stealth
besides that I saw it really oh and even
stealth wasn't that bad I mean Jamie Fox
show makes up for stealth
yeah he seems like universally liked by
everyone too yeah he's never had a
scandal or anything and then he just
kind of became he ended up being a
legend because he just like he not
really quit but he stopped before people
got tired of him yeah that's true he
pivoted he did great and it's crazy he
started off In Living Color too he might
have the best coffee
lady
that ghetto lady oh my God yeah there's
a cross-eyed lady Wanda yeah Wanda so
he's played a sufficient role in every
era of Comedy wow like that era he
killed it like the next Air he killed it
and then he protected Dave Chappelle
from that guy and he beat the shot of
that guy and then him and Braxton
[__] killed it oh yeah
I did that to everybody
hello buddy good answer he was even a
[__] Marvel villain was he oh yeah
yeah the orange Andrew Garfield ones
dude yeah and in the new ones too
because he came back in the Multiverse
stuff for Spider-Man and you know Jamie
Foxx DJs too right
yeah he does and he hopes any host or
heals the Espio
yeah he's a DJ what can he do well you
only get a skill you only get his
personality his personality is sick too
but maybe his personality is he's so
charismatic I haven't seen you know what
I wish the the Legends like would go on
podcasts and stuff because I haven't
seen any of them like oh there's a
there's a podcast where like uh
legendary uh actors they sit in a round
table together and he's in one and he
like pretty much dominates the oh really
he did Rogan's him Robert De Niro was in
it like uh yeah it wasn't yeah they'll
just it'll be all legends those ones
damn it's pretty dope what do they talk
about acting damn that's boring bro I
want to hear about all their stories
like what happened between on tour all
the crazy stuff like that's the stuff I
like to hear I think part of their skill
is is being able to not talk about that
stuff
they give each other the nod to have a
career yeah you know how it is but then
when Bobby's talking about with his Mad
TV buddies on tour and then like having
threesomes with them I'm just like see
that's interesting he almost had his
balls licked by Ari shaffir whoa really
that's a story
but that you know they're all comedians
different different groups they run in
can't have Robert De Niro talking about
that [__] yeah I almost got my balls Joe
pescio must fix my balls he's like oh
that's a good one you should just get
Joe Pesci's Powers dude I'll do Joe
Pesci oh you know I'll take Danny
DeVito's Powers though what are those
what are your precious powers
Joe Pesci plays a good Italian
yeah dude Danny DeVito's just like he's
like it was a wild card Joe precious one
of the few guys this the angrier he gets
the funnier he is oh my God yeah dude
it's the best like the scene in Casino
yeah I like that searching the answer to
Joe Pesci no no I take Warren Buffett
still Warren Buffett huh wow yeah I'll
stick with that why oh no he's so old
I do I become old
no but right now you don't want you
don't like it if you're talking to him
you don't know what the rules are you
don't like your youth I like his glasses
I like his [__] bifolds
yeah I wanted a Toyota Camry yeah the
Egg McMuffin oh my God you have to eat
the same every morning that's my that's
my [__] you're gonna have that uh you're
gonna replace your young wife for that
old hack dude I'd have to lose my wife
too bro she gets his wife you get his
life bro he's a [__] life swap y'all
or some [__] oh dude you got all that
money and you can't even spend it now
that's a curse if I don't get his money
I just get his his skill to do business
still gonna take you a while it's only
ten percent on the S P5 and that's fine
bro that's fine it's compound interest
so it's gonna take you like 40 years
with this skill I can just use all these
strategies now it's just him saving
money all the time what about fictitious
people can or fictional people go for
who are you gonna space MacGyver
oh dude MacGyver my goober's Better
Burger yeah I'll be Roger Rabbit so I
could [__] Jessica Rabbit
well then
that's his skill set you got two you got
two answers on each end of the spectrum
thank you I'll be Popeye dude
olive oil oh God you're tasting women
suck nah cause I just want to get a buff
and strong like I always
beat people up is like eat some spinach
he only beats the same guy up every
episode Bruno I'm gonna Space Jam
[__] Pete Davidson right now
I don't know what that skill is but I
need it his track record is pretty good
man you think he'll end up with anybody
ever you think so oh oh that's a good
thank you hey after a while bro that's a
good one dude that's a catch after a
while you think he just wants to settle
down bro yeah he wants to get married
but they keep using him do you think Leo
ever wants to settle down or you think
it's good just the way he is oh man boy
got to get lonely eventually yeah I'd be
sad I'd be like I'm always the rebound
guy yeah how come nobody want to love me
imagine going to TGI Fridays every day
you just get the sample
yeah is that his thing no
but yeah you're right you gotta get
lonely eventually they just want to use
me for my body and [__] trying to be
used for my body you are used for your
body dude
it's called dancing oh [__] why do you
want to make your mouth like that but
I'm doing it really hard yeah yeah
he's hardcore bro
oh
foreign